I'm in the I do believe this guy looks
like my dad I'm gonna be him
no he doesn't have cool outfits goddamn
a cool one yeah swag oh oh what what
what okay oh oh cool oh just gonna blend
in here how do i okay for a clan that
means boom okay got it got it I think I
think I think I see the one okay wasn't
him do you know it wasn't I throw coins
in their face somebody's running kill
him oh my god oh damn skills don't ski
oh yeah piers you're gonna have trouble
playing this game why are there so many
others rights and why does everyone copy
each other this is like the YouTube
comments holy [ __ ] but what is that guy
doing but hey how you doing there I
wanted to ride on the rail
uncool that was my rail I keep finding
it guys but every time I approach you
you just do something mean I guess why
are you stabbing me I'm innocent
oh you little bat [ __ ] it wasn't her
I knew that [ __ ] oh god what happened
hey wait wait let me pass wait I'm not
dead you didn't kill me really crying
yeah oh how does that feel okay it
wasn't you yeah I'm gonna run over here
[Music]
you can I've said ah don't slap me on
record don't slap me I think I'm too
stylish I'm attracting too much
attention oh come on you hook
some guys walking through a pillar nice
going dude hey man how you doing what's
that the wrong one I don't punch me in
the face
all right you punched me in the face
mark it was supposed to hurt you were
gonna kill me
oh man there's horses not gonna lose his
[ __ ] I found you you little weasel I see
you now you little sneaky Snuka is that
a double decoy stop punching me in the
face please die you have to punch me I
have glasses
Oh God someone's running around me I
don't like this ed Gary's attacking my
hand give me pause cheatengine how do
you achieve in this game i minx how you
doing okay that wasn't minx it was me
but stop punching me in the face that
was nice
silly why does everyone punch me in the
face because you tried to stab me of
course I would punch you fifth place
hell yeah that's what I wanted first
place oh I have a belly button look at
that thing
looks so good are you alone where the
girl is no no no mines visible yeah uh
yeah belladonna is not good unless it's
visible it's like a nipple
exactly Sheldon we changed the mapping
between the game yeah oh we're going to
Tampa Bay now are there pirates in
Florida there used to be really that's
why there's so many crazy people here oh
nice thanks for that so many hot girls
especially me in the middle wait do do
they run sometimes or is like a run
running a dead giveaway stop fighting
guys oh yeah damn everyone
[Laughter]
really oh you need to stop that's not
fair my have a mustache but there are
some will find a new target
don't you worry wait a number one I'm
number one why would you stabbed an
innocent man I'm just trying to walk the
stairs now I'm laying on the state of
since then
you like this sliding just for you
crying why would you twist the man's
neck an innocent man's neck I'm owed
that back though [ __ ] you great wait you
get points for touching people yeah I
got 50 points just looking at him as
nipples I'll take them thank you saying
what yeah I'm just having a stroll in
the beautiful town of Paula Paula ballet
what was it called Portobello I nail
that eNom no I got the season theories
before I die wait you have the same time
kill cry yes bananas no that wasn't her
who was it 900 points whoa whoa I don't
know because I stab you in the front
that son yeah it does because it's like
hey I'm here what's that come here
I'll take Fortin place I am the lack in
it so many people on my ass already how
does that feel good vibes good bye I'm
just sleeping signing don't worry about
me I don't know
it's happening here but I don't like it
oh god I hear whispers no you don't what
are you talking about oh right minx what
are you doing climbing no no Swedish
booty not Swedish booty hey man how you
doing good seeing you I totally killed
him you pierced my nose when I stink
I pierced your focus yeah my life back
then was so easy you just walk around in
my repeat I don't know how a lot of
whispering yeah I don't know what's that
you don't I this is my room
this is my trophy what what the oh my
god this is my turn I'm jumping in pond
I know we're playing game son trap yeah
you could lay it down to decide
somewhere and wait crow that's what you
do for teleportation 900 points thank
you thank you
900 don't play this game I know you went
after me I know I can chase them what
are you doing megaminx allah hands up on
the roof
- oh god oh god oh god help
he's crazy try to die wait you're not
even my target your finite oh I'm alive
well that guy is you shocked the
pedestrian my target it's a guy named
Pedrosa and he's trying to climb thing
good night Pedrosa it's been the play
I'm going no no no you're not even my
target I don't know why not be hey let's
let's just hang loose trace yeah we're
just gonna hang up alright that's my
target I should I missed what what is
happening crying can I come play please
thank you thank you thank you appreciate
you guys anymore hey I remember remember
that time we claimed that lying together
it was so special to me that was my kill
that was the way I was my kin why don't
you do that might I finish him with a
kick that's beautiful le bonheur crying
cry I compliment your belly botton
yearning saying whatever
[Music]
okay there we go
I don't think I'm supposed to smile like
that